BATTLE INJURIES WHICH HE HAS
CERTAINLY DONE OVER HISOUT HIGHE
THAT'S MCCABE IN FRONT OF THEND
BLOCKING ALL THE WAY TO J BEAGL.
>> KAN
BACK IN LINE.
HERE'S THE THEYTRYING FOR THE W.
BRINGING IT RIGHT RIGHT TO
THE E  IN THE
SERIES THIS WAS THETHIS TEAM HED
THE
>> WHAT A MOVER OF RIGHT IT NOW.
>> IT IS
>> THE ONLY PERSON IN THE
BUILDING WHO KNEW IT WAS IN WAS
IS IT.
>> HE DROPS.
>> PATRICK KANE I .
HE ASSISTS OTS
AND SCORES HE MAKES THE FIRST
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE GOAL.
HE GETS HIS POCKET DOWN WELL AND
HE THROWSTO THE CORNER
COYOTES COYOTES AT THE TURN OF
THE OTHER
BACK OUT
>> THE OLD WILY VETERAN
WHAT A GOAL  NET.
HE COMES PLAY TIME 52
SECONDS.
ERICKSON IS THE O IN.
>> IT'SINED WITH THOSE
INJURIES BUT THEY OPE TASTE OF .
HE WAS SHOUT OUT ALL THE HAWKS R